die münchner drogenszene und selbst
polizisten gehören dazu wir haben
darüber mit einem echten insider
gesprochen einem früheren drogendealer
in münchen
mein name ist felix krull ich bin
ehemaliger kokaindealer hat von der
unterwelt bis zu heißer seite hier in
münchen die leute mit paketen beliefert
pakete sind solche kleinen kokain
kapseln der extrem die da kommt aus
gutem hause gerät im laufe seiner jugend
irgendwann auf die schiefe bahn bis 2015
gilt er in münchner szene clubs mit der
droge kokain war einfach so otto ich
halte meine kunden versorgt habe und der
kundenkreis der ging halt im endeffekt
so von unterwelt bis hin zu heißen seite
jeder da war so indirekt alles dabei
jetzt kommt heraus sogar die münchner
polizei ist in ein kokain skandal
verwickelt kennst du irgendwelche
absprachen die es gibt zwischen club
betreibern und der polizei oder auch
zwischen dealern und der polizei gibt es
so was hier in münchen
das gibt's auf alle fälle also dass es
eigentlich auch
alle gar nicht anders möglich weil die
meisten
drogen werden eigentlich dann konsumiert
oder soll ich meine szene drogen wie
kokain jetzt in dem fall
während kohl konsumiert in den clubs und
da ist es eigentlich immer so dass
siemens gibt es einen stamm dealer gibt
rouladen von dem eigentlich intern jeder
weiß okay der ss und dann herrschen da
eben auch andere absprachen wie in dem
fall jetzt also
wie weit dieses netz geht aber ich kann
nur sagen ich habe das zwar ein offenes
geheimnis dass die polizisten davon
wissen wir sind bild und wir liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren